if the democrats were
were to have hired you hypothetically i
know this is not going to happen
if they were to have hired you and said
look we want a hundred percent
uh accurate answers here they put you on
a lie detective test
and said here's the panel of all the
candidates that we have going up against
trump
who do you think stands the best chance
going up against trump
pre you know when they put their
candidates up i'm talking about buddha
chit i'm
all these guys two men and women all the
leaders of the democrat party
are communists they're racists
and they have no respect for american
principles you can't declare a
resistance to a duly elected president
and not be an enemy of this country our
whole democracy is based on the peaceful
transition of power
that's why we have honeymoons for
incoming presidents barack obama who was
an extreme leftist
got a honeymoon that lasted more than a
year
trump didn't get seven seconds they
you know met at a hotel at the mandarin
oriental
this is all in my book blitz by the way
at the mandarin oriental in washington
pelosi was there
elizabeth warren was there the communist
the street communists who managed occupy
wall street the anti-fog people they
were all there
and they formed a resistance to a duly
elected president
the last time that happened was in 1860
when lincoln was elected
then they conducted this phony
impeachment process for three years
knowing from the outset that it was
based on lies
that there was no no evidence imagine
imagine accusing the president of the
united states
of being a traitor of being in putin's
pocket
of putin to having something over his
head which nancy pelosi is doing
to this day to run him you want to hurt
the american people that's what you do
to their commander-in-chief
if you were an enemy you know if the
mullahs had a psychological warfare
unit that's what they would be dead they
are doing undoubtedly
one of them who's been nominated or is
mentioned as a lead
is the head of the black caucus karen
bass
she's a communist she's that was a
leader of the vince ramos brigades which
was run by cuban
intelligence uh for decades
that's the kind of people that they they
uh have
all that said i think that it would be
stupid not to
pick susan rice who's a pathological
liar who lied
about the benghazi buried our heroes in
benghazi with her lies
she's the only one who's really
qualified to be a
vice president
you